[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[ __ ] i dropped a harmonica inside the
piano
[Music]
yes
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for the challenge savannah to
play the piano without actually playing
the piano
and then guys please send me challenges
in the comments below for more seeing
sounds videos like these
it's clear that i just have nothing
better to do with my time
thriller bro and speaking of time and
saving a hell of a lot of it my friends
and sponsors
of the seeing science videos epidemic
sound do exactly that
epidemic has extended their sound
effects library to include 90
000 high quality effects they also made
it really easy for us to save time
searching and finding sound effects by
improving the tagging and categorization
both their product and their catalog of
tracks and sound effects is built with
you
in mind so it's easy for you to focus on
what you do best
i work with epidemic sound all the time
so if you support me go over to the link
in the description to support them too
and get a 30-day free trial
and what's even better if you'd like to
create a track out of the
non-traditional parts of the piano like
i did here today
together we have created an album with
all the sounds that you can use from
percussion
to melody it's super simple to use so
head over
to the link in the description and check
it out today please subscribe
and please comment below so that the
algorithm starts suggesting my videos
again
i'm sorry algorithm that i haven't been
uploading for a while now but it's about
time you stop punishing me
other than that don't forget you're
awesome bru and i'll see you next week
[Music]
you